the recent events in afghanistan show us
how precarious international stability
can be
new challenges can emerge
and issues in far away corners of the
globe can quickly turn into threats at
home
so labor welcomes increased cooperation
with our allies
australia and america are two of our
closest security partners and sharing
resources and intelligence with them and
enhancing capabilities makes them safer
makes britain safer
and makes the world safer
the lessons of the past few weeks is
that britain must look after our most
important relationships or our influence
and security
quickly decline
so mr speaker well labour welcomes this
announcement
but can i ask the prime minister to
outline in a bit more detail what the
agreement means in practice
the strategic review identified china as
a systemic competitor
and china's assertiveness does pose
risks to uk interests in a secure
pacific region
in stable trading environments
and in democracy and human rights we
need to deal with those risks defend our
values and defend our interests
but the same review also rightly stated
that the uk must maintain a commercial
relationship with china and we must
work with them on the defining global
issues of the day like climate change
and pandemic preparedness
without diplomatic strategy and skill
those goals
will come into conflict
so what plan does the prime minister
have to ensure that this new arrangement
increases rather than decreases our
ability to influence china
in order to protect our security and
interests we also need to look after our
broader alliances
nato remains our most important
strategic alliance
it is also the most successful it's
delivered peace and security in europe
for three quarters of a century
and whatever the merits of an
indo-pacific tilt maintaining security
in europe must remain our primary
objective
so can the prime minister guarantee that
this arrangement will not see
resources redirected from europe and the
high north to the pacific
and can he guarantee that this
arrangement will strengthen rather than
weaken the nato alliance
including our indispensable bilateral
relationship with france
we also also in the five eyes
intelligence sharing arrangement with
canada new zealand australia and the us
and that of course is vital to our
security
so can the prime minister assure the
house that this new trilateral
arrangement will not weaken our
intelligence capabilities by producing a
two-tier five five-eyes operation
finally mr speaker this arrangement
clearly brings potential economic
opportunities for britain we need the
well-paid high-skilled jobs that the
defense industry provides in every
corner of britain the prime minister
said this project will create hundreds
of skilled jobs so can the prime
minister give more detail on what he's
done to ensure that britain gets its
fair share of any contracts that come
out of these arrangements and what will
he do to ensure that no region or nation
in britain misses out on any job
opportunities that this arrangement may
bring thank you mr speaker